YUFENG GUO: Don't you just
love setting up your computer,
installing libraries,
configuring them, and making
sure they're all compatible?
It's just so much fun.
No?
Yeah.
Me neither.
That's why we're going to skip
around all that nonsense today
using Deep Learning VM Images
on Google Compute Engine.
Welcome to AI Adventures where
we explore the art, science,
and tools of machine learning.
My name is Yufeng Guo,
and on this episode,
we're going to check out how to
take advantage of Deep Learning
VM Images to make setting
up a new environment a piece
of cake.
The Google Cloud Deep
Learning VM Image
makes it easy and
fast to instantiate
a VM image containing the
most popular deep learning
and machine learning frameworks,
all on a Google Compute Engine
instance.
It lets you launch Compute
Engine instances preinstalled
with your choice
of ML frameworks
like TensorFlow or even PyTorch.
And you can easily add Cloud
TPU and, of course, GPU support.
You can either
instantiate the image
using the Google Cloud
Platform Cloud Launcher UI
or from the command line.
So now you get to use
your favorite open source
tools even sooner without having
to keep them up to date or deal
with installation troubles.
The Deep Learning VM
Images are prepackaged
as a click-to-deploy
virtual machine that
can be accessed in
the marketplace,
formerly known as
Cloud Launcher.
Search for Deep
Learning VM and select
Launch on Compute Engine.
There, you can select from
a number of different Deep
Learning VM Images
with configurations
of CPU, memory, storage,
GPU, and your choice
of installed libraries.
There are just a ton of
combinations available,
and you can fine tune them
for your specific workload.
The best part is that
unlike a typical computer
under your desk, the
hardware for a VM
can be edited at
a moment's notice.
Need more memory,
double the disk space,
or say another GPU or four?
Just edit away.
Let's take a look at how you
can create these VMs using
the gcloud command line tool.
We will start with the simpler
case of a virtual machine
with only CPU, no GPU.
In this case, we
just need to decide
what zone to put our VM in
and what machine learning
library we want to use with it.
Here's the list of all
the available images
to choose from.
Let's say we do tf-latest-cpu.
The full command to run this
word look something like this.
And once you run this,
it will take a moment
to provision the machine
and install all the software
packages.
Once the VM is up and running,
you can SSH into the machine.
Instead of a
standard SSH command,
I would recommend using
this slightly modified SSH
command, which does a
bit of port forwarding
for you to enable you
to connect to JupyterLab
via your local Chrome browser,
just like you were running it
locally.
Now, when you run
this command, it
will drop you into
an SSH session.
You can poke around there in
the command line if you'd like,
but the real good stuff
awaits in your browser.
Head over to localhost-8080,
and it'll magically
load up JupyterLab.
It'll just be there.
Now we can do a whole separate
video on just JupyterLab alone
but, in brief, it's like Jupyter
Notebooks but way cooler.
You can manage your entire data
science workflow from here,
running multiple notebooks
in different tabs
and with different
versions of Python even
and take some notes,
say, in a text file.
OK.
So that's the
end-to-end workflow
for a CPU-powered
virtual machine.
Now let's say we want GPUs,
because it seems like everyone
wants GPUs these days.
There are a few
additional considerations
here that you'll need
to keep in mind as you
work through this process.
The tricky part of
doing all of this
is that you need to coordinate
just a couple of things
to get these GPUs working right.
First, let's take a look
at what GPUs are available.
As of this recording,
there are options
that include the K80,
the P100, and the V100.
So you'll need to perhaps
do a little bit of research
to choose which one
you want to use.
Once you've decided
on your GPU of choice,
check out what regions a
given GPU is available.
You can see that shown here.
And finally, head over to your
Quotas page in Cloud Console
to ensure that you
have enough quota
to provision a machine with
that combination of GPU
in that zone.
This final step is crucial to
getting your VM provisioned
successfully.
If you don't have
the necessary quota,
go ahead and click
on Edit Quotas
and submit a quota request.
On the surface, it seems
to be all about having
the necessary quota.
But it's a bit more nuanced than
that since the quota specifies
not only what model
of GPU but also
what region that GPU sits in.
OK.
So say you've figured
out what GPU you want,
what zone it should
be in, and confirmed
that you have the necessary
quota to provision it.
Now let's look at how to
actually get a GPU-powered Deep
Learning VM going.
The step that differs from
all the previous CPU workflow
that we just saw is how we
actually start up the VM.
We can take the command that
we used before and add to it
a few extra bargains.
First, we'll need to
set the maintenance
policy to terminate.
This is due to the fact
that we can't live migrate
a GPU-powered virtual machine.
So for maintenance, it'll
actually shut down the VM,
but you can have
it auto restart.
So always be sure
to save your work.
Next, choose your GPU type and
count, informed by that quota
deep dive we just did.
And finally add a
piece of metadata,
which will ensure that the
drivers to power your GPU
are installed on your behalf.
It's a couple of
additional steps
to get these
GPU-powered VMs working,
but I promise it's
worth the effort.
Once you run this command,
the rest of the workflow
is exactly the same.
And when you SSH
into your machine,
JupyterLab is there
waiting for you.
And if you do a
PIP freeze, you can
see that the version of
TensorFlow that is installed
is tensorflow-gpu.
So the next time you're
thinking about installing
a bunch of libraries
by hand, remember
to save yourself
some time and energy
by using the Deep Learning
VM Images on Google Cloud
Platform.
Thanks for watching this
episode of Cloud AI Adventures.
And if you enjoyed
it, please like it
and subscribe to get all
the latest episodes right
when they come out.
Now, head on over
to your console
and make yourself a deep
learning environment
in the cloud.